[Music]
AppOn is based in Pune
Was established in 2012.
We develop easy-to-explain games
And improved for emerging markets.
With this huge turnout on smartphones,
We had to focus on these markets to maximize our profits.
They offer us a great number of business opportunities.
Kitchen Story is a simplified simulation game
And skills management.
You must cook different types of food
To compete with various international chefs.
When Kitchen Story was at the theoretical level,
We were taking into account that it was
Game size is less than 20 MB.
Beginning, in India, there are many
Of the challenges we face.
The first of these challenges is hardware compatibility.
The second is the cost of data.
The third is low-performance devices and language support.
So you have to make sure that the game
Compatible with all types of devices
And performs the same performance on all devices,
Whether the device is expensive or cheap.
We learned from our previous mistakes
That the development of a large-scale game
Will lead to catastrophic consequences in these countries,
So we are really excited to develop a game
Smaller and faster performance.
Working with Google, we've discovered the best possible way
To minimize the size of the game.
The first method is to use Noto fonts instead
Custom fonts, because that reduces
The size of the applications facilitates the possibility of
Translate your games into other languages.
Second, embedded formats are useful for content
In animation, user interface and effects.
Using built-in forms helps content
In greatly reducing the size of the game,
We make sure that this does not adversely affect the user interface or experience
Best use of color tables.
The images are similar to color measures,
Where you can fill color tables and indexes
separately.
After that, you can change the color table
And get a completely different picture.
We developed the game so that it works without Internet,
Because in India, some users may not have an Internet connection
All the time.
We also transferred a lot of gaming data or assets
To the electronic cloud.
We have so far received almost 6 million downloads
And more than 100,000 comments with a rating of 4.4.
Initial retention rates
Really high because the game is easy to learn
Therefore, retention rates on the first day rose to 60%.
We always focus on developing light and fast games
It offers a great user experience.
These technologies that we have used so far,
Part of our business strategy.
We continue to use these techniques in our new games.